I wanted to get everyone's name wrong
okay a good night for Trump but a bad
one for the media in tone and tenor
Trump seemed to nail much of it like his
uncompromising rejection of socialism we
are alarmed by the new calls to adopt
socialism in our country
[Music]
America was founded on liberty and
independence and not government coercion
domination and control we renew our
resolve that America will never be a
socialist country well unlike the
juvenile try put forth by the naive
faces of the opposition party his words
speak to the soul of anyone who
remembers the Cold War Bernie Sanders
face said it all
how dare Trump badmouth his favorite
fantasy still however there was a lot
here for the Liberals to like shrinking
the military footprint paid family leave
aids funding childhood cancer treatment
yeah all they can do is stare blankly
with all the seriousness of sad pastry
chefs how do you know when you've done
good when the people who can't stand you
all look like villains at the end of a
Karate Kid sequel but there was also
good stuff for righties too more defense
spending a defense for the unborn a
hard-line stance on Russia and China
NATO paying its fair share if I didn't
know any different I'd say that was
something for everyone and Trump did
stress unity we must reject the politics
of revenge resistance and retribution
and embrace the boundless potential of
cooperation compromise and the common
good we must choose between greatness or
gridlock results or resistance vision or
vengeance incredible progress or
pointless destruction sounds
conciliatory no wonder the media hated
it I saw this as a as a psychotically
incoherent speech with cookies and dog
poo every leader whatever your party
should be talking about climate change
it's just we could have a debate about
it he's the president's at this moment
in the world did not mention climate
change and even a sentence is just
frankly a disgrace I have to say the
word socialist is now becoming a
buzzword like liberal and feminist where
the right wing is now taking that word
and distorting it it's being what the
bastardized that were congratulations
fan Jones
he said dog poop are the new Ben and
Jerry's flavor so right on cue they
react out of anger and fear fear that
Trump wasn't divisive which threatens
the business model for conflict leads to
profit and conquer compromise won't pay
the bills then give the reality check
from CBS 76% of viewers actually
approved of the speech that's a contrast
with the Dems in the media could it be
they were facing the wrong direction all
this time which is why the Democratic
response written befores Trump speech
fell flat it was like an NFL commercial
after a final play you know who won
so why stick around for that alright
let's just go around this lovely table
and ask what people's favorite or least
favorite moments are when I start with
you Dana what bugged you okay I'll tell
you something bugged me I loved a line
yes yes in which he's talked about we
are going we need to define a new
standard of living for the 21st century
because I felt like that was a line that
was a big umbrella yes and it's a it's
something that in all these different
places we talked about AI disruption
worker retraining the need for education
should we go to college or not all those
things and it was very visionary and big
and then there was like nothing yeah
like wait that's a good umbrella and
maybe they'll come back to it so that
bugged me a little bit I also thought
that the social is a moment was amazing
yeah it's like the first time a
president of the United States has to
stand on the floor of the House of
Representatives and tell the country
that we are not going to do socialism
I'm interested in joy Behar's yes that's
your take on socialism becoming a war
like we we didn't call something
themselves that exactly pointing out
what it is I mean I that's a great point
making it up I also thought that for
Stacey Abrams you know my rule always
say no to give me the response to the
State of the Union you will never have
the stage that the president has but as
those things go
she got out pretty well yeah yeah well
you know you like water but you didn't
watch the speech you know right no she
could is that a point-by-point rebuttal
you already like have a response what it
does
what you think the state of the union
looks like well you were crawling with
good points today
anyway Jesse what did you what struck
you I was impressed that the president
was able to get Democrats to chant USA
USA USA wow that was a nice moment to
hear I thought he successfully took
unifying historical achievements in
America like landing on the moon and
landing on the beaches of Normandy and
made people focus on that towards the
future and say these are the kind of
patriotic things we should rally around
another key line I thought was this was
an American agenda not a Republican or
Democratic agenda and victory isn't
winning for our party victory is winning
for our country and he challenged the
Congress to choose greatness instead of
partisan destruction I agree with Dana
the socialist line telegraphed 2020 he's
gonna say therefore socialism for
freedom and you know he's smoked Hillary
imagine what he's going to do with an
actual socialist yeah it's going to be
deadly laid out areas of cooperation
like NAFTA and I think medicine prices
and things like that but I think I was a
real sucker for the end when he said you
know for from the rocky shores of Maine
from the volcanic peaks of Hawaii we
need to kind of keep faith in American
destiny keep America first and keep our
souls together and it was a beautiful
finish and my part that I didn't like
was when all of the women dressed in
white were applauding louder for
themselves yeah and then they were for
American people and their
accomplishments that's a good point can
I just jump in not to step on one but
because my favorite moment is because
Trump displayed what a master showman he
is he is a one-man good cop bad cop
because he got all those Democratic
women to stand up and applaud themselves
and then few moments later he was like
oh by the way I'm proposing a ban on
late term abortions and he caught them
sitting there but they can't applaud for
the life of an unborn child and he in
terms of 2020 he is going to force
everyone running for any office in the
Democratic Party to come out and say
okay I want to be one of the seven
nations in the world that allows
abortions after 20 weeks my favorite
moment with Nancy Pelosi was I have
resting be face just like Nancy Pelosi
where I look at rest like I'm a Kutcha
yeah she had to actively look Pleasant
that entire speech it is exhausting to
do that it's like running from DC to Des
Moines so she gets she gets some
applause from I love the abrupt but
we're talking about her applause later
you know one I appreciated your call
last night when you said Greg you're
right it was a really great speech I
didn't save the voicemail though because
the ghost in the phone would have been
delighted but I must say those are good
good drinks that you've been here you
know so to me this was you know last
night says a humdrum speech and the
reason I said that it was it sounded me
like color by the numbers on calls to
unity and then he would go and
immediately throw out some red meat to
the base on the kind of immigration
stuff where he'd you know distorts
numbers about immigrants
oh that caravans approaching they're
deadly you think oh my gosh is he doing
back to this same old song again look
everybody knows that was a one-hit
wonder and it isn't working and he
doesn't talk about the fact that the
national emergency thing is totally
ridiculous even among Republicans at
this juncture but in answer to your
question about a favorite moment I would
go back to the women standing up and the
women applauding themselves and Trump
acting as if he was the one who brought
all these women to come you're welcome
know here's Danny Dana what's funny is
but you know what it's the alternate
universe that he tries to present it's
like watching all these Republican white
men and dark suits and then you watch
this diverse group of women and you say
hey so this is what Trump has brought to
their narcissism they love cheering
themselves gave him a nice moment like
he was recognized
he's a narcissist who was saying he
deserves trying to take credit one is
having fun my favorite moment when they
sang happy birthday to them that was
great Gilbert somehow responsible even
singing no he stopped because he was
trying to take advantage of a moment but
I think once again singing happy
birthday